this is the MIT comparative Media
Studies and writing podcast
I'm Andrew Whittaker and today I want to
introduce you to Lily chin I'm Lily chin
I'm a senior here at MIT I'm in course 6
2 which means electrical engineering and
computer science I'm minoring in
mechanical engineering and minoring in
comparative Media Studies she's
incredibly smart in high school I did a
lot of math and science competitions
heavily involved in robotics and
research competitions and the baddest
Polymathic as you can get medical
services president of MIT 'he's
paleontology interest-group trapshooting
little clay pigeons gets thrown into air
I shoot him down with a shotgun and what
someone like that do for kicks I was on
the 2-week Jeopardy college championship
can
fifteen people are competing from
different universities and there's a
semi finals a quarter finals and I made
it all the way up to the finals and I
won winning both $100,000 and a trip to
the next jeopardy tournament of
champions that's right a hundred grand
quite the story there aren't ready but
we also wanted to know what interest
someone and an Institute of Technology
heading to a grad program in robotics to
also minor in comparative Media Studies
I was sitting behind someone and then I
was looking over their shoulder and it
looked like an academic paper except
there were screenshots of Mario and I
was like what is this it sounds amazing
so let's get to know Lily chin her path
to jeopardy champion and the story
behind her now famous Final Jeopardy
response but then we'll talk to her
about how a media studies education
helped her deal with the weird aftermath
of becoming other people's media object
even hours first walk me through how you
qualified okay first there's a online
test that's held in October so I just
kind of took it on a whim I actually
took it during one of the cs classes
that I was taking but fortunately I
qualified so it wasn't just totally
goofing off in class well yeah what did
you mean you took it during class so the
test is a 50 question test and they only
offered at one time to prevent cheating
you know like during the middle of
discussion I was like quickly like
reading a trivia question and I had ten
seconds to answer it so typing in the
answer before moving on to the next one
so yeah yeah that was the online test
how did you find that that you were
picked you take the test in October and
then in November they give you an email
that just says like show up in New York
at this time and they don't pay for
transit so I took the mega bus up there
and you go to a hotel you take another
on written test and you also do a like
interview portion so you play a mock
game of Jeopardy and the contestant
producer Maggie kind of interviews you
and should make sure you're good for
television good for television what does
that mean yeah so so one thing that is
really funny is that Jeopardy is
fundamentally a TV show so they're
looking for like as it's charismatic and
I was like extroverted as you can be
so for example like at the auditions
they she asked everybody to dance and
I'm like very sure that's one of the
reasons why I got chosen because I was
just like I don't have anything to lose
so I just now
danced really well tell me about your
dorm mates reactions okay so and then
November I was over in New York and then
December I got the phone call and so
it's sort of funny because you get this
California area code and you're all
excited and then you go through like 15
minutes of paperwork and then they're
like if you can guess already you're on
Jeopardy but afterwards I was just like
running up and down Hall being very
excited and I think it was funny because
like my friends immediate reaction was
like we get 10% of all your current and
future earnings lovely walk me through
what happens next she has to get herself
to LA she arrives at a hotel paid for by
the show then maybe surprisingly
maybe not the show immediately takes
steps to prevent cheating
they keep lilly away from other
competitors they make her sign
non-disclosure agreements and no one
gets close to jeopardy host Alex Trebek
that's all followed by the nerves you
get from the hurry-up-and-wait that
comes with television production one
restless night like I couldn't sleep at
all that first night like waking up
every two hours just very nervous
then weird taken on a bus and the
contestant producers their cameras start
rolling immediately then because they
need to start getting b-roll footage for
the YouTube videos and then it's an hour
long bus ride from Universal Studios to
Sony Pictures studios and during that
time Maggie the contestant producer is
just giving us the lowdown of like how
the format works like general strategies
she's she's been most of the staff on
Jeopardy has been doing this for 30 plus
years so she's got it down pack so now
you're in the studios and you're sitting
in the green room and you're doing more
paperwork and then pretty much after
doing makeup and paperwork then it's
time to get on stage picture yourself at
the podium now in the College hoodie
cameras are directly in front of you
just to their right just ten feet away
from you is the iconic six by five wall
of categories and clues next to it
Trebek and then turn dear far left unlit
so they're practically a black void is
your audience
the game start and Lily of course kicks
butt Lily whose Lil Wayne Lil Wayne yeah
Lily who is Rick and Morty good Lily
what is a radius
what are tulips who is iris iris yes now
what I didn't know games aren't played
one per day production grant as many as
they can into single shoots was just
minutes between it's not only intense
but surreal since the college
tournaments multi round structure means
players are in the building but sealed
off from the set stuck waiting their
turns so because of that everybody's
actually sequestered in the green room
until it's their time to play because
otherwise if you knew the previous
scores you'd have an advantage
fortunately I was one of the first
people called so I didn't have to wait
in a green room but everybody else was
just kind of twiddling their thumbs
watching movies being very nervous and
just waiting so yeah so that was the
first day of shooting just getting all
the quarterfinals done then went back
home slept second day of shooting it's
now it's now the semi finals and the two
day finals all packed into one day and
there's literally only 5 minutes between
games so in the two day final it was
basically you know go to the green room
change out of your sweatshirt get your
makeup retouched and then you're back
out there so it's very funny funny
she says I'll mention funnies a word she
uses a lot but you hear how it's often a
catch-all how she described anything not
a hundred percent comfortable but first
let's hear about the two questions
jeopardy viewers always have for players
how do you win and what's Alex Trebek
like in person turns out on Trebek even
players don't really know I think it's a
question lots of people have he can't
really afford to get close to the
contestants because I think they said
he's one of two people that has access
to both the contestants and the
questions and they're really nervous
about the quiz show scandals of the 50s
so they don't really let you get that
close the one thing I thought was really
cool about Alex Trebek was that he's
into machine shops and like
do-it-yourself repairs so I'm a
mechanical engineer and just like I
can't I really want to see what Alex
trucks machine shop looks like because
it sounds really nice tell me about the
gameplay did you go in with any kind of
strategy did you feel like you had an
edge yeah um
so I definitely studied a lot beforehand
I think this was the most I've ever
studied for anything that's an MIT Steen
no straight up because um I mean you
always sort of do it like the night
before maybe two nights before if you're
ambitious before it test but here I had
like a one-month lead time and there's
$100,000 on the line she said that to
prep
she read Wikipedia articles she dug up
her stuff from high school quiz bowl she
actually researched which categories
came up the most state capitals
presidents Shakespeare top 40 now I
don't know how much she was trying to
sound extra humble playing down the
insane amount of work it took to Hoover
up so much trivia but it sure sounded
like downplaying her smarts when she
said I think a lot of the game ends up
coming down to buzzer strategy so
usually everybody already knows the
answer by the time it's time to buzz in
so then what they do is that they have
lights on the side of the big grid of
screen a grid of screens that will turn
on after some guy and some production
staff thinks that Trebek has done
finishing or need a question but if you
wait for that then it's all down to
reflexes so the the strat that people
say online is that you have to judge
right when Trebek finishes the question
so that you know you'll buzz in like sub
reaction time still she's going to tell
me oh everyone knows the answers you
just have to buzz in best so I pressed
her and she got a little more candid I
feel a little bit guilty because I don't
really have any close ties with the TV
show and there are some people here who
are like oh I watched a TV show like all
the time you know and this is like my
dream of going up but then they didn't
really prepare for it which is something
that struck me is weird but preparation
this is where you start to see how MIT
students are on another plane Lili's
major has a class in probability and
statistics and it showed so like one
thing is that since the quarter final
amount right you eyes are win your game
or you are one of the four next highest
people right so you don't know what the
cutoff is but you can look at historical
cut-offs and she went even deeper with
the math
and the data is already there like
someone ever you compiled it and says
like oh the average amount you need to
go to move on is $12,000 so I was like
okay I'll put my bar at like 15,000 of
what I'm shooting for and some of the
other contestants just didn't even have
a number that they were shooting for now
tell me the story of the final Final
Jeopardy oh goodness
um so it's a two-day final and so it's
basically how many points that you rack
up over both days so when it came time
to the last Final Jeopardy I did the
math and I realized that there was no
way that the second-place person Gary
from the Navy could bet any amount and
he would still not be able to catch up
to me so before the tournament started I
was kind of thinking to myself like oh
what joke answers would be good to put
down so I knew I wanted to put dank
memes or spicy memes memes that have
overstayed their welcome it turned out
to be a Whois question astronomer who
began his epitaph I used to measure the
heavens
now I shall measure the shadows of Earth
the answer I can get Trebek to say
whatever I want we come to Lily chin she
had 20400 going into final today
and her response who is the spiciest
meme Lord all right let's see what your
wager was nothing so 20,000 400 today
twenty thousand four hundred yesterday
gives you a total of 40 thousand eight
hundred
[Applause]
and then it just hit me right then it
was like what did I do
like I was like I guess like if you
spend time on the internet you will know
it but if you don't then you have no
idea what's going on so this was
something I would have like said to my
friends and I didn't think too much
about it but when it finally aired on
the episode like the Internet freaked
out about it okay so she just won a
hundred grand with an answer she knows
is gonna blow up online but she can't
breathe the words of it to anybody
you're back in Cambridge here in your
dorm what's it like before the first
show airs I knew that I already couldn't
tell I couldn't tell anyone like I
couldn't tell my family I couldn't tell
my boyfriend because otherwise like then
I'd start telling everyone but like
there's always these little things that
you want to bring up like you know the
song panda will come up and I'll be like
oh I want to tell people that this was a
question and that like I only got it
because I studied or you know just or
like I can't believe all the other
people playing missed an overwatch
question which is like very also very
relevant to me um
but yeah uh there were some people in my
Hall like every day this kid would come
up to me and say like so did you win did
you win it all and like it was a lot I
was I was definitely waiting for the
episodes to finally air so I could get
something off my chest but even your
boyfriend you didn't tell your boyfriend
no and there wasn't like but I'm your
boyfriend we don't keep any secrets no
no no my parents were a little salty
though especially because my aunts were
there at the screening but my parents
weren't so my odds kind of went like in
the Entertainer you don't know what
happened and then what did your you know
door mates friends family thank as you
kept winning oh they were estatic um it
was really funny because uh sort of
first round
it was Bible books of the Bible and my
Hall is fairly secular so when that
showed up they're like oh who knows this
and everything and then they saw like
immediately I had written down the
answer very fast and one of my friends
was like she Iser really knows it or she
has no idea what she's doing so there
was just a ton of hype about everyone
just like cuz you couldn't believe what
was going on
I
I think because I won so handily in the
first game I think administrators also
started taking notice - I was very
surprised to see an email from rife and
my inbox from president rife and he was
like congratulations you know like if
there's one thing to describe MIT spirit
right now its nerd pride and I was like
wow like president right going out to
email me yeah
and then as it just kept going like the
the support kind of grew alums from the
1970s were emailing me and it just kind
of ballooned until like finally yeah
yeah the final game and that described
the scene of you know if it's a watch
party or whatever when you won oh so I
was very insistent not to host a watch
party until the final game because I was
like I don't I don't want to organize
this because I knew I was gonna have to
organize the last one and so that was
fun it was I I bought some snacks and
then also some people brought their own
and and we got out one of the classrooms
in building 4 and just kind of all
clustered together and during the
commercial breaks I would kind of we'd
mute the volume and then I would sort of
like do a little Q&A so then then the in
the last commercial break the one before
Final Jeopardy people are saying like
you have a lockout game and I was like
yeah I did and then just just that
moment when everyone just started
cheering for me that was that was really
good and then like the next turnaround
when like the final Jeopardy answers
revealed and its spiciest name award
like oh my gosh it was it was insane my
I was getting like 100 notifications
every time I checked Facebook because
you know even people from high school or
being like you're an absolute madwoman
like what are you doing
geez yeah it's been crazy I polled folks
around the office about they wanted to
know from lily about half of them are
played what happens with the money one
even asked its cash right a suitcase of
cash so it's funny they hold your money
hostage until you until your episode
airs so you to keep to make sure you
stay quiet but I got the check and I've
cashed it in and yeah feels good yeah
some some large numbers in my bank
account Tremont's here's what things
start to get less comfortable for her
and where it seems like her media
studies work may have added a layer of
armor
the average contestant might not have
all right so the final episode airs
after that what changes for you um I
mean I think that changes had been going
on like the entire time like because
there's you know people are messaging me
whether it's like people I know like MIT
alums or not or random people on
Facebook because I essentially doxed
myself like all of my personal
information of my full-name where I go
to school where my hometown is that's
all put up by jeopardy so it's very easy
to find me online so yeah people are are
Facebook messaging me I'm ignoring most
of them because like it seems very we it
never occurred to me that you can sort
of reach out and talk to people through
the TV and that the fact that people
like feel like it's okay to do that this
is it's strange um I also have been
looking like after at each episode airs
I'm looking at Twitter I'm looking at
Facebook I'm looking at Reddit just to
see sort of the commentary because it's
it's very weird being suddenly this
national figure right people are around
the country are messaging that's the one
thing I was not expecting is that what
it means for a national TV show now I
her you to be on one and also one that
is like as culturally a touchstone as
jeopardy right so I held an AMA on
reddit because people were excited about
that well what's what's an AMA oh it's
asking me anything so famous people will
say like you know ask me anything and
you just respond to questions on reddit
and just the diversity responses were
interesting one of them was their wife
was a combination videogames studies and
psychologists
so using videogames and treatment for
psychology so he was interested on like
asking on behalf of her like oh what
research are you doing you're gonna be
at PAX East you know to talk about this
another person was you know does Sean
Collier memorial true you might not be
familiar with the MIT campus but the
Collier Memorial is this extraordinary
five-pointed structure a vaulted granite
erected to the spot where MIT police
officer Sean Collier was gunned down by
the Boston Marathon
he worked at the company that cut out
the stones for it so he he actually had
never been to MIT so he's curious like
Oh where's the Sean Collier memorial
located like it doesn't get a lot of
traffic and then he said like oh because
you like lathes and stuff like here's a
picture of our whole manufacturing setup
and it was very impressive the one
message I responded to from a random
person was this person telling me how
her daughters were in middle school and
really interested in chemical
engineering and just seeing me on TV as
this figure and like you know both had a
technical school but also like clearly
having fun saying spicies meme Lord was
really inspiring likewise another person
on reddit was saying that they were in
the hospital for a family emergency and
so they were watching jeopardy because
like an elderly one of their elderly
relatives was sick and then when the
spiciest meme Lord comment came on they
were just like it was such like an
unexpected moment of levity in that
situation so like it's it's very weird
right like people are coming to me use
these stories I'm I'm a part of people's
lives even though I didn't expect to be
I'm getting a lot of press
like I guess discounts for one and like
you know there's a research convention
for high schoolers I'm apparently on par
with a Nobel Prize laureate to go talk
to it same thing for my old robotics
regional back in Georgia they want me to
come talk to it it's it's very strange
I'm taking full advantage of it because
I know this is not going to come again
but it's it's very weird very weird she
says and remember how I mentioned her
use of the word funny it wasn't exactly
positive
have you felt respected through the
whole process ah that's really funny um
so like I guess respected innocence of
like congratulated and that people are
really like excited to that I'm doing
very well and I do appreciate that but
at the same time there's this process of
claiming that's going on which i think
is really interesting i'm still not sure
how someone can sound so media studies
like analytical about something so
personal
so here we get into what MIT and Wien
compared to media studies prepared her
for we hope but at the same time our
role is kind of ambiguous as she points
out even we are claiming her the CMS
department for one like you know would
you like to do this interview and be
claimed as one of us or even someone in
my dorm who I didn't know I met her in
the hallway and then she was like oh
you're despise me milord
oh I'm going to claim claim you and like
you know oh I totally hang out with her
all the time in my door and stuff and
that's very weird because it's it's a
sense of like ownership and property
right and you know it so it's like all
of these different communities I've been
a part of whether it's my high school
whether it's my robotics team all of
them now want to like kind of join in
and say like oh like I know Lily chin
and like let me let me ride this wave I
don't know if that counts as a respect
or not it feels very weird I guess right
when I was in high school I was in they
I did very well in a research
competition the Intel Science Talent
Search um but again that also had a very
fancy component at the end there was
like a gala everyone I dressed up fancy
to refer to stand for prom basically and
a lot of high achieving like DC of
people came you know like a high like a
senior VP of Qualcomm a you know
Department of Energy came you know a
couple like probably House of
Representatives congressman came but
what was really funny was that for me
this was like the culmination of my
scientific achievement I had worked
really hard on this research project and
now I thought I was going to get honored
on this stage but talking to some of the
other that did like the invitees there I
guess um it was more of an excuse for
them to sort of rub shoulders with one
another and it felt very weird is like I
am an entertainment object for you know
like I'm the backdrop for this fancy
dinner that's not being held for me but
sort of for them what was the moment
that you knew people out there weren't
seeing you the way you saw yourself well
I would say that would actually between
the between the waiting time between
like waiting for my episodes to
and after I had shot them because I
found they I found some articles I was
starting to look more into jeopardy and
one of them was from a past contestant
who talked about her experiences was
harassment uh so she had actually um she
had also done a very funny joke answer
of relating to the Saturday Night Live
skits about celebrity jeopardy
um so so now that's one of the clips
that I was like constantly brought up as
like funniest Final Jeopardy answers
just like I know I'm gonna be
memorialized like that but the thing
that really struck her is that she found
one of those clips and then looked at
the comments of them and they were all
about her physical appearance you know
um and she was really kind of put off by
this and so she did a little bit more
digging and sure enough she found a
whole bunch of other like women who had
had the same harassment stories of just
like appearing on national television I
think it's also really funny that in the
so like there's an informal network of
past jeopardy contestants and part of
the things they show you is the Zoe
Quinn's guides really quick what's like
the two sentence synopsis of gamergate
Zoe Quinn was a developer um some
reviewers said that she was sleeping
with other people for positive reviews
this like kind of snowballed into
attacks on women in gaming attacks on
indie developers attacks on game
researchers yeah so if you're laying
link to like Zoe Quinn's guide to
cyberbullying right this is kind of yeah
that's a big deal I don't think it was
ever going to be that bad like in some
sense my appearance was fairly
androgynous which is sort of funny
because a lot of people on like reddit
we're also very confused which I which
was really funny to me that like you
know how do you care so much but it
confused why there was a literally a
debate in the comments it was like oh
she seemed this person seems masculine
was a feminine voice oh really like to
me they seemed feminine was a masculine
voice hmm and I I thought that was
really funny
funny again strangers debating someone's
masculinity our femininity online in a
place they know Lily will see it again
she's so level about something that's
pretty upsetting but this ability to be
aware of how she comes across
even in 140 character objectified
version people create seams to keep her
saying that's true even here as she
points out how TV producers could and
should step up their own awareness how
they can make it a point to prep
contestants for what comes after they're
on TV I think but I think also that
saved me from some of the harassment
that like other female contestants
probably got which is also sort of funny
right like is that you'd have to reduce
your femininity to remove harassment but
whatever I think it's also funny that
they don't tell you this like this came
from the community of contestants it
didn't come from jeopardy I think that's
also partly because the show is so old
and it's not like you know in the 90s
you would expect like oh yeah so-and-so
from that place like I can totally just
find them on Facebook and message them
there's no expectation that you can
break this boundary between television
and viewer when I had always watched
jeopardy I never thought about the
people on it like it was just oh this
person's answering more questions or
just person's getting more money but to
me jeopardy was always a vehicle of just
getting trivia in you know I didn't
really care about the people there and I
think there's a reason why asides from
like Ken Jennings or Arthur - or Julia
Collins the only major celebrity of
jeopardy is Trebek right he's the giver
of the trivia you know I'm with you I
you know I might follow and all the
sudden I've watched jeopardy I might
follow someone who's on a hot streak but
it never occurred to me to be involved
in their lives somehow or even talk
about them outside of my own house what
why do you think people do that
I think people probably did this already
like I think it just depends on what you
pay attention to right like if there's
only like one female contestant you
might be like oh I'm gonna cheer this
person on definitely for college things
that's definitely like a Navy go Navy
beat army you know and I think now it's
just become a lot more public with it
like Twitter was by far the most like
like racy I guess and I think it's
because like you have your own little
Twitter stream and it is like you can
put so much information in it right so
all you can do is just put like very
short sentences you know or even just
like thoughts and you know if it's the
first thought that comes to your mind is
that like oh like so-and-so is bad or
like so-and-so is attractive that's
that's what you're gonna put down which
I thought about that a lot because the
the earlier article I talked about about
the the harassment that women got after
being on Jeopardy that sort of scared me
quite a bit to be honest um I don't know
and I think the worst part about it was
that it wasn't just like random tweets
this time it was direct Facebook
messages so you know not only early you
like wanting to close the gap between
you know spectator and like media object
but you're also wanting to like send
this sort of hate directly with your
name attached so what if anything at MIT
prepared you to be this kind of media
object not sure prepared um like in
terms of all describe it this way you
seem able to remove yourself from the
experience and kind of analyze it in a
dispassionate way in a way other people
might not be able to is is there
something about your education here is
it helped you do with it I think part of
it is that I've spent a lot of time on
the internet and also in like the
not-so-nice part for the internet so I'm
used to like this posing and you know um
I don't know just like very raunchy
behavior and so I was I felt more
nervous about like actually the people
around me getting attacked right
so one thing funny is that one of my
friends
do you know moot the creator of 4chan no
um so this was back several years ago
but the essentially one of my friends
got confused
somehow 4chan was trying to find the
identity of who created fortune just say
real quick what does give people
background on what fortunate if that's
if that's possible
fortune is an image board which means
that it's just a bunch of like you post
an image and a quick comment by it which
seems innocuous except one people can
post anonymously and like - it's very
rapid fire and the turnover is a lot and
somehow it kind of turned into like this
that's pool of like whatever
um so yeah that's why we were the most
like offensive stuff if you're looking
for it you'll find it on 4chan um so
yeah so the creator of 4chan was
actually anonymous for a while he went
by moot and one of my friends was
mistaken for moot because they didn't
like the IP address searches and like
tried to find like oh he's roughly like
teenager living in this area of the u.s.
and they somehow found my friend's house
so like his mom
he was a 4chan user so he knew it was
going on but his parents didn't so they
would just be like getting like these
random packages or like these random
phone calls and it's not even for like
that person it was for some internet
alias that it's not even correct so I
think that's what I was most scared
about I think is that people like going
around the family but the one thing I
was really surprised about is that like
once I started getting me a first bits
of hate I was just like laughing because
it was very petty
and just like seeing people who like
clearly are just forming an impression
on like why like 20 minutes of footage I
think the thing that's really making me
like be able to take an analytical look
at this is my comparative Media Studies
training so I were I this is what's
allowing me to like look at the
different forms of media of like how is
the response on Twitter versus a
Facebook and what parts of the media or
medium are possibly causing this to
happen and then I remember I brought
this up with my professor right now for
color and film eugénie brinkema and just
talking about like yeah there's these
really weird things about like I think
because I'm androgynous I'm getting less
harassment there's these weird things
about becoming a media object and seeing
the means of production and she sent me
like a whole list of papers and
everything to read and saying that you
know when I find when I'm confused about
a situation theorizing about it really
helps and I think that's that's actually
been really true right like the more I'm
reading about it I like one of the
things that she linked to was Monica
Lewinsky however a Vanity Fair article
talking about like what's it like to you
know be so prominently in the spotlight
and like trying to hide
remove it or pretend it never happened
and like coming to terms with it and one
of the things that was in the article
was um that it's this desire to take
back the narrative that's been created
and I think that's that's really true
and probably something that I'm feeling
very strongly right it kind of goes back
with the idea of you know different
areas are claiming you for their own
purposes and you're not really making
any decision yeah I definitely don't
think I would be able to make these
connections without comparative Media
Studies yeah so you're compared to Media
Studies minor yes but you're at an
Institute of Technology
yeah um it's also kind of funny how I
got into a CMS minor actually yeah how
was that because when I first came to
MIT I was very into like math and
science and I was like ah you know like
great I'm gonna do all the math and
science and it's kind of annoying that I
have to take so many human these
requirements but then during my intro to
algorithms class I was sitting behind
someone and then I was looking over
their shoulder and it looked like an
academic paper except there were
screenshots of Mario just like
interlaced in there and it was like what
is this this sounds amazing so I just
keep down like peeping over his shoulder
until like I found the name of the class
and it was CMS 300 intro to video game
theory and literally like during that
class I kind of planned out my course
road of Oh like I wanted to take the
film experience already and that counts
for CMS that's great like oh I can take
all these cool classes so I got I
decided on a CMS concentration very
early on but then it never occurred to
me that I could do some substitutions to
make it a CMS minor until later on and
then I've I've I feel I actually feel
really happy that like I've been invited
to do this interview because like I've
always wanted to be like accepted into
the CMS department because it is sort of
funny right like most people feel like
if you do if you humanities focused at
MIT
it means you couldn't cut it you weren't
cut out for it in science which was
blatantly not true right like I think
all of the people that I know who are
into humanities here have realized that
it's actually like a valuable part
you know it's not just to be so
technically minded but actually being
aware of other things and it really I
really feel like it enriched my time
here at MIT do you think you would have
studied something like compared to Media
Studies if you went to a different
school I don't think this exists in the
different school to be quite honest
right like the classes here I've taken
are insane
I've taken interactive narrative with
Nick Montfort I've taken games and
culture with TL Taylor I've really
enjoyed you Jeannie bring commas class
whether it's film experience or color in
film
she's like single-handedly the reason
why me and several other my friends are
actually pursuing human these degrees at
this point because just her like sheer
force of like man I don't know if you've
ever had a conversation with Sarah but
she's just so intense and it just really
gets you excited about the subject
material and all these people are like
I'm very well-known in their field
right like Montfort like wrote a book
about interactive fiction like TL Taylor
sort of set the stage for massively
multiplayer online games and sort of how
does that fit socially in the
sociological perspective now in my job I
tell a lot more stories about faculty
and graduate students then I get to tell
about undergrads this was a good chance
then to ask Lily about the undergrad
experience at MIT you can't help but see
how incredible it is but it's so so
tough MIT has this drinking from a
firehose metaphor about its education
today that hoses psi has been turned
down a bit you see in here a lot more
about the value of taking care of
yourself how to do it what the support
resources are but as I've learned the
pressure on students comes not so much
from educational demands big as they are
as from their peers observing one
another
as they find ways to make the most of
four short years in Cambridge the the
insidious thing about pressure at MIT I
think is that it's it's all you put it
on yourself she says just after telling
me she's coming off an all-nighter I
don't think the school is has it has a
cuts through environment I don't think
your peers are cutthroat but I think you
start comparing yourself to your peers
you want to be hardcore but you know
it's too
a long time for me to realize this but
like now it's like oh I should
prioritize my health and not just like
my schoolwork students listening take
that to heart despite how she finishes
this interview when I asked her this
looking back on your jeopardy experience
was there anything that you think you'd
do differently
I don't know study her study more but
this is in the context of health and
well-being because what she means is
even fun things like games can be hard
work my department which Lily joined
after catching someone studying games in
the middle of another class has an
aversion to gamification that if you
just slap a game on top of something
hard it's magically not hard but to your
brain to your life what's to gain by
doing only what's easy if you're at home
for leisure watching jeopardy or playing
Grand Theft Auto or cards against
humanity' let it be as easy as you care
to make it but if you're gonna go on TV
national TV and be as chill as lily was
with knowing what comes after eyes wide
open you're golden because like her in
Final Jeopardy you know how important it
is being prepared with the right
response
this episode was produced by me with
engineering by Matt Russell editorial
help from Chris couch and music by Jody
Boswell
it's all a presentation of MIT compared
to media studies and writing and
everything about us our degree offerings
our research and yet bar podcast is
online at CMS w MIT edu
you